and we discovered this a formula for
finding out what your Bond girl name
would be and what you do is you take
your grandmother's maiden name do you
know this and your pet no best pet
you've had no that's our that's your
porn star that's a porn star name what
this one this one is it's your
grandmother's maiden name for username
and then when you were kids the nickname
you had for your genitals is your first
one so I would have been Winky Reynolds
if I was a Bond girl
what would your a Bond girl there'd be
just believe it with me for a minute
okay groaning you know you want to tell
us I can see you on surface talk
Hargreaves
[Applause]
Hargreaves yeah Eve is better than that
what would your bond may be and it would
be pinky Morrissey binky Morris inky
Marathi it's adorable
more than binky Marjorie Newman are you
following the formula largely are you
guys related
so you were the one who called it
Marjorie presumably you decided to call
it margin
[Applause]
we'll just keep Margery under wraps
what was it as Finola McCarrick
[Music]